[Music]
all right so I want to talk about
climate change and what we know and what
we don't know and before I do I just
want to remind you of what you've heard
this morning that science marches in a
very erratic way we begin with
observations maybe conjectures followed
by experiments sometimes theory and it
goes back and forth and there's a few
empirical observations about giving an
example of how this works as a physicist
I go to the government and I'm there for
430 years and in the very first cabinet
meeting I say to the president mr.
president in bureaucracies everything
comes to a halt and less continually
pushed in fact Newton was wrong
Archimedes was right everything is
government by friction another empirical
law the first law of politics get
elected there are three laws second law
of politics get reelected third law
when in doubt consult rules number one
and two all right so as one gets
information you might reject the
information and because of that
antibodies come out and and we discussed
why that is so if it conflicts with your
held beliefs strongly held beliefs
that's what happens so what are the
tactics that are used and in the out
sights we call this food for fear
uncertainty and doubt and what you do is
you spread fear that this knowledge
might lead to a government regulation
and that regulation might actually
conflict with your worldview the way you
make of living and so you begin to
reject it and you actually have you
muddy the waters by spreading
uncertainty so if science says this you
find someone else that might say
something different
ideally assigned has but if not a pseudo
scientists it
matter if the ratio is 5,000 to one that
doesn't really matter the press is happy
to interview that one in 5000 and then
you use fear and uncertainty to turn
what would be healthy skepticism into
denial okay
so here's some information this is the
land and water temperatures around the
world averaged around the world the
first question is are these measurements
accurate was there bias in the
measurements maybe you make more
measurements around cities which then
actually tend to raise the temperature
so on and so forth but this has been
worked out over many many years 20 plus
years of challenges reassessments I just
want to remind you that this is a recent
phenomena we talked about the beginning
of the Industrial Revolution but most of
this rise has been since 1976 now let's
talk about climate change this is some
change in climate but if you look back
at the history and there are three
graphs the bottom graph is the
temperature where the extreme right hand
side is the present time and going
backward 800,000 years and look the
climate is changing we are in a warm
stable period but before that there was
an ice age there was another warm stable
period only about one to one point two
degrees warmer than we are today
ice ages ice ages ice ages Neanderthals
roamed the earth at this period of time
Homo sapiens came at this period of time
and I can assure you based on a strong
faith that Neanderthals weren't
responsible for climate change but you
see the other thing methane carbon
dioxide there was no Industrial
Revolution there was no massive human
emission of carbon dioxide and you
noticed that there strongly correlated
so you can say well the climate is
changing
carbon dioxide cycles with temperature
so this is a natural phenomenon well is
it by the way that's where we are in
carbon dioxide and methane so we're
going off the charts so
this is the more recent past in the last
10,000 years and then all of a sudden
the change looks a little bit funnier
there's a long stable period and all of
a sudden carbon dioxide seems to shoot
up and we're right now over here and you
look at the time scale over the last
10,000 years and you find out 3/4 of the
increase in carbon dioxide has occurred
over the last 65 years but it's more
worried than that the rise in carbon
dioxide actually matches what we
estimate was being emitted by human
activity and not all the carbon dioxide
is up there
in fact 45% gets very quickly absorbed
by plants in the ocean and so we also
understand that so if you believe in
accounting this is very consistent
however there's much more compelling
evidence that this is not a natural
cycle and this is very important and
seldom discussed in the press and it has
to do with carbon-14 now listen to me
for a moment don't look at the pictures
let me tell you how carbon-14 is made
it's made in the upper atmosphere
cosmic rays protons bombard nitrogen and
turn into carbon-14 you all know the
carbon-14 is radioactive that's what we
use for radioactive dating this
carbon-14 diffuses down in the upper
atmosphere into the biosphere you and I
have carbon-14 in ourselves and there's
some mixture of carbon-14 notes we have
mostly carbon-12 but a small fraction of
carbon-14 now you go you're buried you
die you're buried hopefully you die
first you're buried let second but and
they put you in a really good coffin
completely separated from the rest of
the earth and five thousand seven
hundred years only half the carbon-14 is
left another five thousand seven hundred
years another half that's left another
quarter is left and you go on and go on
and go on after a hundred thousand years
guess what no more carbon-14 in you
then they assume you put you in a power
plant you and your friends and generate
electricity now if there's enough of you
and your friends generating electricity
that goes up in the atmosphere there's
less carbon-14 okay so is there a big
enough effect now we look at on the blue
line in the red line the increase in co2
we look I'm only really talking about
the Green Line we look at this and the
ratio of carbon 14 to carbon 12 is going
down this is a wait you're you're
stopping the data in 1950 what is going
on well it goes a little off scale the
carbon 14 zooms through the roof why
because the odd States and the Soviet
Union started testing H bombs in the
atmosphere that makes a lot of carbon-14
and you see it was in the northern
hemisphere followed by the southern
hemisphere the oceans began to pick up
the carbon-14 first in the northern
hemisphere then in the southern
hemisphere everything's being diluted
it's going down going down going down
but how is it going down now in the
recent pass it turns out the dilution of
carbon-14 is also consistent with how
much fossil fuel were burning at the
very least the amount the dilution of
carbon-14 means it had to be isolated
from the environment for many lifetimes
trees don't do that they live they die
they get recycled by microbes much of
the ocean doesn't do that so this is
convinced most scientists and then
carbon-14 in the ice cores also
convinced well scientists this is unlike
any other change this is different all
right
so there's a claim there in warmer
periods and now I can speak about how
the opposition creates the uncertainty
and they say well we've just come out of
an ice age and they actually take
scientific data legitimate scientific
data and they say this is from an ice
core the same ice core that we use to
measure climate change one ice core in
Greenland and look at the
they say you talk about unprecedented
warming the headline was Greenland ice
core analysis reveals multiple peers
prior to 20th century where there's
unprecedented and you see the warming
Bronze Age Iron Age warming the Little
Ice Age in the medieval times cooling
and they say look we're just coming back
to average this is nonsense
okay so what's going on well it's data
selection if you look at all the data of
all the ice cores and you bring it up to
date you find I'm sorry we're out of
that now okay when the new data appeared
it was invisible on the conservative
blogs none of that you picked the data
that most reveals what you want to do
and so when people scientists select
data they're going into very very
dangerous territory you just don't do
that so let me talk a little bit about
um okay five minutes when I was in
Washington much was said about that
little plateau between 2001 and 2013
where there was a leveling of
temperature why was there such a big
deal there because the climate models
predicted that the temperature would
increase on over this 10 or 12 year
period didn't increase so the reaction
is you guys don't know what you're
talking about this is crazy and they
didn't talk about the earlier time but
just you know over the last 10 years so
what was going on why did the climate
models miss that plateau and so it was
suspected that perhaps the heat went
into the ocean but you don't conjecture
that you go on measure it and so what
scientists did is they dropped these
yellow boys that's the thing in yellow
not the person in white and they dropped
them all around the ocean and they go
and they report the temperature of the
surface they go down two kilometers
they're measuring temperature and
salinity as they go down they measure as
they come up they radio information back
they last for about four or five years
that B runs out you say well this is not
going to really tell you what's
happening in the oceans because you know
what are a few boys the oceans very big
and
you'd be absolutely right you drop a lot
of different colors are for different
countries the whole scientific community
was taking part in this dropping things
everywhere and the conclusion was what's
us were actually worried about they're
not worried is the greenhouse gas effect
real they're not worried is the earth
warming up
we knew what energy was coming onto the
earth where was the energy going well ah
energy is conserved
okay it was warming up the ocean but we
weren't able to predict the slow ocean
mixing and changes with any accuracy so
it's not that greenhouse gases are wrong
where our precision of our models was
not like that you can go on our glaciers
melting as the sea level rising toward
answer it's yes again satellite data
gives the most convincing data
perturbations in the orbits of
satellites with GPS with radar actually
tell you if the local mass is changing
and so with that we find that Antarctica
which was supposed to gain in mass was
actually losing a mass during this
period of time the yellow was gaining
mass but only in the first half of the
observation period was a gaining a mass
unbalance the whole of Antarctica was
losing it was supposed to be gaining
because as the earth warms there's more
evaporation more snow in Antarctica but
Antarctica is cold so it should have
accumulated ice mass didn't surprise so
we missed that and so I talked about the
last warm period one degree warmer the
sea level was 69 meters higher that is
not a climate model that's a measurement
based on dating seashells that died
during that period of time
see she cell critters that live between
land and ocean all around the world and
so what's a little scary is we used to
think that would take many thousands of
years to come to this new 6 to 9 meters
higher the UN goal 6 to 9 meters higher
sea level but now we're frightened that
it might take a hundred or 200 years and
so this is what
coming on all right now another final
claim and that is you know fossil fuels
are very abundant oil gas and especially
coal and so renewable energy will always
be less expensive and isn't it the first
priority especially in developing
countries to grow the GDP because you
first get them out of poverty then you
worry about what rich countries worry
about and the fact is they say that
renewable energy will remain cheaper for
many decades but that's actually simply
factually not true if you're rural India
where you're not tied to the electrical
grid or sub-saharan Africa or Western
Alaska what you find is you have to
generate electricity by burning diesel
and bunker fuel and then in all sudden
renewable energy wind in Alaska solar
many places else becomes a low-cost
option by fourfold fivefold and so this
is becoming a reality in developed
countries wind and solar is actually
becoming comparable to fossil fuel in
the United States the cheapest forms of
energy are number one natural gas number
two win number three solar and coal is
so far behind that the Trump
administration has asked the Department
of Energy to say write a regulation that
says because coal has all this fuel
on-site its energy security so they
could be allowed to charge more money
that's what's happening today and what's
also happening today is you notice the
satellite data is most compelling they
want to defund that satellite
measurement data they want to fund
defund the climate measurements
especially the best climate measurements
but they know what they're talking about
the other final thing is that there is a
real cost to society the PM 2.5 is
turning out to be far more deadly than
we could ever imagine so let me end the
talk by just reminding you of one of my
favorite pictures taken on Christmas Eve
1968 called Earthrise and the astronaut
who took two
said we came all this way to explore the
moon and the most important thing is
we've discovered the earth so look at
that picture the moon is not a good
place to live the Earth from that
vantage point looks great even up close
it looks great
notice everything black all around there
is nowhere to go since 1968 the climate
we found the climate is changing
compelling evidence there was human
activity that's changing this and we
better fix it thank you
[Applause]